joining us now with reaction to all of
tonight's big his stories North Carolina
congressman mark meadows House Oversight
Committee ranking member congressman Jim
Jordan good to see you both
mark let's start you know Schiff has a
lot of problems here no wonder the non
whistleblower whistleblower a friend of
Biden friend of shifts and he lied about
contact so I guess he doesn't want him
to come Nancy Pelosi apparently doesn't
have the votes for a real impeachment
inquiry that would say that probably
gonna have a hard time impeaching even
though there's nothing to impeach over
yeah obviously tonight Nancy Pelosi
decided to not put a resolution on the
floor which would hopefully start the
process process of it being fair I can
tell you Jim and I have been now in over
40 hours of deposition and what we're
finding is is that Adam Schiff only
wants to have witnesses who will give
the response that he hopes that they
will give and even at that it's a swing
and a miss I you know we need to have
that whistleblower and we call it a
whistleblower but it's really more an
anonymous informant we need to have them
come in so that we can say how often did
you coordinate with Adam Schiff did he
help you and in filing this so-called
whistleblower complaint and why did you
not let everyone know that you had
contact with Congress those are the kind
of questions the American people need to
judge for themselves Jim Jordan you've
been watching the circus now go on for a
couple of years everything they accused
the president of they themselves are
guilty of okay look at shift is shift
compromised if you know do you think
hunter Biden is compromised because or
Joe Biden I you know if if these
countries make all these great deals
millions of dollars for his son to do
nothing with no experience I got to
imagine they're thinking that they're
probably going to get favorable
treatment from as their father that's
just a guess of mine no you're right and
and Mark's exactly right to I mean Nancy
Pelosi and Adam Schiff are trying to
impeach the President of the United
States thirteen months before an
election based on an anonymous
whistleblower with no first-hand
knowledge whoo-hoo announcer suppose no
first-hand knowledge and and
who went in front of the who went to
Adam ships committee first I mean think
about this Sean though the whistleblower
gets a the call gets info about the call
writes a memo and then waits 18 days
before he files a complaint and who's
the first person they run off to see
Adam ships staff and and and they don't
mark the form either Sean they don't
check the box on the form that says we
talked to people on Capitol Hill so yeah
Mark's exactly right why do they now not
want the whistleblower to come in at all
because we got all kinds of questions
when did he actually come to you what
took place there that's the problem with
this whole thing this unfair partisan
process they're they're undergoing okay
so where does this go next is Nancy
Pelosi all of those Democrats I'll
scroll the names again those that were
elected in districts that Donald Trump
won in 2016 I got to imagine most of
them are saying this is going to destroy
my career this is my district does not
want to play into this madness mark
Meadows well here's where it's going to
go the the Democrats are going to write
a report they're going to come out of
these secret rooms where they've been
where we believe there should be cameras
an open transparent process but they're
going to write a report and that report
is going to take only a certain amount
of the information information that
they've actually tried to lead the
witnesses to conclude and then they're
going to put it into the judiciary and
they're going to say oh this is the most
damning thing that we've ever seen since
the Muller report and it's time to
impeach and yet what the American people
are going to see it for what it is
and Jim's absolutely right thirteen
months we could have an election let the
people decide
in November of 2020 they actually vote
though will they vote to impeach the
president well I think right now yeah go
ahead Jim well we don't know Sean but
you're right that my guess is the reason
the Speaker the house is not bringing it
up for a vote to start this this
so-called impeachment inquiry is because
those folks in those districts that
President Trump won they're probably
hearing from their constituents they
were just home for two weeks and they're
probably saying what the heck is going
on we're sick of this why don't you
start dealing with the issues we care
about instead of trying to impeach the
president we all
elected we all elected 60-some million
people voted for we all elected and in
13 months there's going to be an
election so why are you doing this I
think that's the reason the speaker's
holding back okay and Sean and Sean Jim
John's Sean
Jim's exactly right I was I was with
governor Matt Bevin last last night in
Louisville Kentucky and what we're
hearing is not just in North Carolina
but Kentucky and all over people are
outraged that somehow their voice is
going to be taken away by a few
Democrats in a secret room it's just not
American and it's not legitimate
transparency weren't they the same
Democratic Party correct me if I'm wrong
they wanted to pull Buller report
release so we could see it they won't
let us see anything they wouldn't let
Matt gates in yesterday a member of the
United States Congress a member of the
Judiciary Committee and tonight they
wouldn't even let members and came to
the Intel room to read the transcript of
ambassador Volcker they wouldn't let him
read it unbelievable
pretty corrupt guys thank you